so i'm going to talk about why lemon
water is essential if you're doing
fasting
and the ketogenic diet now
typically when you think of lemons you
think of acid right
citric acid and lemon juice and lemons
are really good to decrease the risk of
kidney stones because they help
bind with oxalates okay and most kidney
stones are
calcium oxalate stones there is some
vitamin c in lemons okay but
not if it's in a jar and it's
pasteurized
because the heat destroys the vitamin c
the other
side note that you need to know is that
any time you consume vitamin c in your
body or any food with vitamin c
and at the same time you're consuming
sugar
what's going to happen is your body is
going to absorb
the sugar but not the vitamin c because
their chemistry is very similar
the body will always absorb sugar before
vitamin c
and i can think of like lemonade for
example where
people take the lemons and all the sugar
they're thinking oh yeah i'm gonna
get some vitamin c no they're not okay
so
there's some other benefits of lemon
juice or
lemons and you could use the juice of
one lemon which is one ounce of lemon
juice or just lemon juice
for what i'm going to recommend now
what's interesting about citrus in
general
and lemon juice or lime juice is that
after you consume it
within one hour that acid turns
to an alkaline substance it turns
alkaline
so lemons are good for people
that have acidosis where their ph
is slightly too acidic okay that means
the ph has dropped
down now normally the blood ph should be
between
7.35 and 7.45
okay now anything above 7
more alkaline so the blood is naturally
alkaline
but if it goes below this 7.35
you start developing a condition called
acidosis now here are the symptoms for
acidosis
shortness of breath your breathing is
affected
labored breathing deep breathing
headaches because you're actually
getting
too much co2 you're tired
confusion tremors sleepy
arrhythmias increase heart rate
okay so these are all the symptoms of
acidosis
what's interesting about that is there's
this concept that if you're too acid
you're always unhealthy we need to
alkalize the body
okay alkalizing the body for every
condition is a good thing
uh including cancer but that's actually
not true you don't want to be too
alkaline
you don't want to be too acid you want
to be exactly right where you
should be but in this video i wanted to
talk about the symptoms of being too
acidic and what causes that and the
remedy
would be lemon juice and you can put in
your water so what
causes our bodies to become too
acidic keto
and fasting could do it now
if your body is healthy you're not going
to develop acidosis
okay from this right here but ketones in
general
are acidic and when you do a ketogenic
diet low carb and you do fasting
you're going to have more ketones you
might have more acid in the body
and so drinking lemon juice can help
reduce some of the excess acidity
if your kidneys are damaged you can
develop acidosis
if you have too much iron you can have
too much
acidosis alcohol will put you in a state
of acidosis and then you have a
condition called lactic acidosis
i've done some videos on this i'll put
the links down below
but this occurs when you consume
metformin which is a medication for
diabetes one of the side effects would
be lactic acidosis
but really this mainly occurs if you are
b1 deficient
if you're consuming a lot of carbs
that's going to deplete b1
or refined grains especially so
if you have acidosis taking b1 can
greatly
help that now ketoacidosis is very rare
this only occurs if you're a type 1
diabetic and you fail to take your
insulin
so i mean taking lemon water is not
going to create a big
change for this if you're interested in
more information i put a link down on
this but
this is very rare and this is not going
to happen to anyone who is
healthy so if you do a keto diet or
fasting you're not going to develop this
unless you're a type 1 diabetic and you
fail to take your insulin it delivers
damage
you can actually go into acidosis from
that excess
exercise can also put you in a state of
acidosis now there's other things that
can do it too for example
if you're consuming a tremendous amount
of apple cider vinegar or
you do kombucha tea like uh in the past
i remember drinking a whole bottle of
kombucha tea
very very acidic and i definitely went
into a state of acidosis because my
heart rate
started going very very high just
pounding and pounding and pounding
and i had some of these symptoms my
breathing was off
i couldn't sleep at night so
what i did is i drank some lemon juice
okay
bam handle it so realize that the lemon
turns alkaline after about an hour and
it'll start to adjust your ph
that way there's certain conditions that
will cause this
and there's certain conditions that will
cause this
and you want to be right in the middle
right here if you're doing fasting
if you're doing keto i would recommend
to do this even while you're fasting
take some lemon maybe about one ounce
put that
in water drink that down and that way
you can help minimize
this condition right here and some of
these symptoms
thanks for watching
hey we're back with another amazing
recipe no grains
no sugar totally keto there's no
suffering in keto absolutely not karen
and it's an immune system builder
absolutely you have to check this out i
think you should hurry up
watch the recipe and make it yourself
it's just so easy to be keto
but is it simple it's super simple we
hope you enjoy
making it as much as we are enjoying
eating it